so here's a Dragon Ball Z design element
that I actually didn't notice for going
on two decades it's a pretty minute
thing but for some reason in the boo Arc
toy made an internal change to the
lighting of Super Saiyan so to speak
before the arc if a person was super
saiyan but there wasn't an aura then
their clothing and skin was lit just
like they were in their base form and
then of course when there was an aura
then their skin was lit more harshly
because of the glow but in the boo Arc
they changed the logic here because
Super Saiyans even when there isn't an
aura had a different skin and clothing
tone when they were in their base forms
and again I'm aware how Niche this is
but it kind of breaks my brain a little
bit like does this mean their hair is
emitting light at all times or I just uh
I'm kind of lost here help me out in the
comments